tu lucha es mi lucha esa fue una de las
consignas que corearon miles de
estadounidenses la crisis del coi 19
nuevito que se reunieran en la capital
del país portando tapabocas para exigir
el fin del racismo y de la brutalidad
policial
estamos marchando unidos por metas
consagradas y de forma oportuna somos
valientes pero conscientes de nuestra
salud mantenemos la distancia social
pero estamos espiritualmente unidos
tapamos nuestras caras pero no nuestra
fe en libertad
[Música]
la movilización se produce en el
aniversario número 57 del famoso
discurso tengo un sueño pronunciado por
el líder de los derechos civiles martin
luther king iii en medio de las
protestas que se intensificaron luego de
que un agente disparara en siete
ocasiones a la espalda de la ffr
estadounidense jake blake quien quedó
parapléjico
hoy haremos un juicio juzgaremos el
racismo sistemático ahora mismo
culpables culpables culpables racismo
contra todos nosotros racismo contra
goerges floyd son culpables racismo
contra jake blake son culpables durante
la concentración los ciudadanos
defendieron la necesidad de votar en las
elecciones de noviembre y evitar que el
presidente de donald trump siga en el
poder para los manifestantes el jefe de
estado defiende y fomenta el racismo
trump ha centrado sus discursos más
recientes en ponderarse como la única
figura que podrá poner orden en el país
y garantizar la seguridad de los
estadounidenses no obstante la convulsa
situación que vive eeuu por las
protestas y el coi 19 ha hecho que la
imagen del mandatario se desplome y de
acuerdo con las últimas encuestas se
encuentra ocho puntos por debajo de su
rival demócrata joe biden
[Aplausos]